have you ever tried EMDR that's what we
did that's what I did and it will make
that work dude
I've never been that hysterical in my
life where you keep doing the same thing
a lot of that events you Oliver stay
there stay there close your eyes follow
my finger follow my finger yeah buddy I
did the machine I didn't think I was
worthy enough I was like now this is for
pts this is for like veterans people who
lose light I didn't think my [ __ ] was
and all of a sudden she taps into
something yeah and this devastation I
felt as a kid comes out and what's crazy
about this is there's some science to it
but then you know that happen but it
doesn't affect you the same way that and
it worked for me it worked for you so
you were able to acknowledge that it
happened it's there you somehow forgave
him well what happened was after going
after leaving there and eating when I
was eating I thought to myself what
there's there's a connection now between
my my childhood and my trauma and my
body right I could could make that you
know the between the brain and your body
there's a connection between and I
thought to myself oh my god did I I have
to deal with this right so then that's
when I went to pcs and um Arizona how
long for two weeks and it was um from
7:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. you're in you're
doing EMDR should do art therapy
everything expensive yeah pretty
expensive Gucci so you did you go in
there think were you up in mind her at
first you were kind of like and then all
of a sudden you realize wait a minute
something's happening well when I walked
in there the first day I remember the
lady Marilyn Murphy Kent comes out she's
explaining I'm in a group and you're
with the same group of the whole time
right and you're in a group with these
people that are like you know there's
one Orthodox Jewish guy with the little
hairs and the hair Pierce's whatever and
then um you know I mean there's a house
ma you're how wife
yeah you mean you know there had someone
staying with me and like you have to
check out your long
yeah so in the beginning you're like
what the [ __ ] is exactly right [ __ ] but
then it's so funny because when it was
over I didn't want to leave them I mean
they're my best friends yeah you know
you know it is you feel safe for the
first time in your life I bet you really
felt safe yeah and I was so like working
on myself I enjoy um the process of
feeling better and dealing with things
you know so you know by doing that
process I remember I did an EMD hour
session and what they made me do is they
made me go to a mall and go to a
build-a-bear and I go why do I have to
go to the [ __ ] mall and they go well
because we want you to UM make a doll
that represents your original child the
child that first comes out of the womb
you know that needs just love and sexual
attention nurturing all the things that
a baby needs you know and so I remember
getting the doll and I remember um when
I was eating with kalila Kalama went
with me to the mall it was holding the
baby was eating and she cried the way I
was holding the [ __ ] doll you're
holding yourself I was holding myself
yeah and you meant it you were doing the
work yeah you weren't trying to be funny
you were doing oh yeah and then I didn't
that day later that day I did an e MDF
session where it was about one traumatic
experience with my dad and then she told
me to pull out my doll and then you know
tell your original self right you mean
to how you're gonna protect him and I I
ended up on the [ __ ] ground
crying so hard holding this thing yeah
and then um because I didn't greet my
dad and then when I walked out of that
session I said one thing and
like bro for to our
to have people pick me up from the sauce
fault I was crying so hard